und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und eine Gellinek
guten Abend vielleicht hat Robert Habeck
die Bekanntmachung des gasdeals mit
Katha absichtlich heute morgen platziert
oder er hat einfach Glück gehabt
jedenfalls konnte er pünktlich zum
Termin mit der deutschen Industrie mit
einer guten Nachricht aufschlagen Katha
liefert ab 2026 jährlich zwei Millionen
Tonnen Flüssiggas an Deutschland das
sind rund 3% des jetzigen deutschen
Jahresverbrauchs das Energieproblem der
deutschen Wirtschaft löst diese Menge
natürlich nicht und die Stimmung
zwischen Unternehmerverbänden und
Minister hält sich auch nur mäßig auf
was in dieser Lage vermutlich nicht
anders zu erwarten war Frank Buchwald
berichtet aus Berlin
Klaus-dieter Müller weiß was er will
Berliner Bauunternehmer 160 Leute
klassischer Mittelständler von der
Politik wünscht sich vor allem Klarheit
die Wirtschaft und insbesondere auch die
Bauwirtschaft braucht verlässliche
Botschaften und braucht Botschaften mit
denen wir weiterarbeiten können mit dem
wir unseren personalausbilden können mit
dem wir Investitionen tätigen können und
da hilft es nicht quasi jeden Tag eine
neue Sau durchs Dorf zu treiben Adresse
hat solcher Kritik Robert Habeck der
Wirtschaftsminister heute im Gespräch
mit der Industrie die Herausforderungen
so Habeck sein riesig Transformation hin
zu klimaneutralen Märkten
demografischer Wandel der in den
nächsten Jahren voll zuschlagen wird
Sicherung von Fachkräften
Digitalisierung der Unternehmen hoher
Investitionsbedarf also es gab
wahrscheinlich schon bequemere
Situationen Harbeck Umkreis drei große
d-worte Digitalisierung Demographie und
de Carbonisierung dabei erwartet die
Wirtschaft von der Regierung mehr als
nur Probleme Beschreibung die
Rahmenbedingungen dafür dass Deutschland
attraktiv ist auch im internationalen
Maßstab als ein Land in dass man
investiert die müssen wir gemeinsam
schaffen dazu müssen die Unternehmen
ihren Teil beitragen durch gute
Leistungen durch tolle Innovationen und
dazu gibt es natürlich auch
wirtschaftspolitische Rahmenbedingungen
über die wir sprechen konkrete
Forderungen weniger Regulierung und mehr
Vertrauen in die Eigenverantwortung der
Unternehmen von den Behörden mehr
Unterstützung und weniger Kontrolle etwa
beim lieferkettengesetz es geht darum
internationale Partnerschaften zu
stärken dazu braucht es auch neue
Handelsabkommen
gerade der letzte Punkt sorgte bei den
Grünen bisher für wenig Begeisterung
dreh- und Angelpunkt aber bleibt auch
Aussicht von Ökonomen eine verlässliche
Energiepolitik das muss glaubwürdig
dargelegt werden dass es sich trotz der
Unwegbarkeiten lohnt in Deutschland zu
investieren und dass die Energie
bezahlbar bleibt das Grün zu sagen die
Energie wird grün ist zwar richtig aber
das ist zu wenig wir müssen konkreter
sein seit Monaten kümmert sich Harbeck
intensiv um neue Gasquellen ein
lng-termin an der Nordsee etwa wo auch
das lange verteufelte Fracking Gas aus
Amerika ankommt sein Kotau vor dem Emir
von Katar im März hat nun immerhin zu
einem langfristigen Liefervertrag
geführt auch wenn der Minister seine
Rolle heute herunterspielt die
politischen Gespräche waren immer nur
rahmengespräche danach sind die
Unternehmen im Gespräch geblieben das
war immer bekannt und sie haben es aber
die Aufgabe der Unternehmen dann
ihre Verträge selbst zu schließen
deswegen kann ich dazu und möchte ich
dazu wenig im konkreten sagen ein
schlüssiges Gesamtkonzept erkennt der
ifo-Chef bisher jedoch nicht noch haben
wir keinen Plan um die D und
Industrialisierung zu verhindern die
Industrialisierung auch so ein d-wort
sie hängt über Harbeck wie ein
Damoklesschwert
und aus Berlin ist uns jetzt Robert
Habeck zugeschaltet Minister für
Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz guten Abend
Herr Harbeck guten Abend nach Mainz sie
haben einen tiefen Diener vor den
Autokraten in Katar gemacht und bekommen
dafür jetzt 15 Jahre lang fossiles Gas
zu einem geheim gehaltenen Preis wie
fühlt sich das an für einen grünen
klimaschutzminister
Katar liefert jetzt Gas das ist ein
notwendig weil aus Russland das Gas
nicht mehr kommt und die Notwendigkeit
ergibt sich aus der Sachlage das glaube
ich ist parteipolitisch egal wie man da
drauf schaut wir brauchen eine sichere
Energieinfrastruktur aber es kann ja
nach allem was ihre Prinzipien sind
eigentlich nicht in Ihrem Sinne sein bei
einem Autokraten fossiles Gas zu kaufen
oder davor haben wir das Gas von Putin
bekommen das war mit meinem Prinzipien
noch viel weniger vereinbar
auf der heutigen Konferenz hat die
deutsche Industrie ihnen unverblümt
gesagt dass sie Angst hat vor den hohen
Energiepreisen vor dem Ende des
deutschen Geschäftsmodell und vor dem
Aus des Wirtschaftsstandorts Deutschland
mit welchen Argumenten konnten sie die
Industrie beruhigen nun erst einmal ganz
so mit Verlaub war es nicht wir haben
natürlich die Lage sehr ernst analysiert
und die Lage ist ja auch ernst und die
Energiepreise drücken aber es gab auch
einen klaren Blick nach vorne eine
Entschlossenheit dass wir das was wir im
Jahr 22 mit der Energieversorgung
gemacht haben im Jahr 23 für die
deutsche Wirtschaft die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit des Landes und die
Industrie tun das letzte Jahr war ein
Jahr der Industrie und wir haben das
letzte Jahr war ein Jahr der Energie der
Energiesicherheit und wir haben mit
einer großen politischen
Krafteinstellung einer gemeinsamen
politischen Krafteinstellung dieses
Landes
viele Dinge auch richtig gemacht und das
nächste Jahr wird ein Jahr der Industrie
werden die Preise werden runtergehen wir
werden den Standort in Deutschland
sichern mit welchen Argumenten haben sie
die Industrie beruhigt das waren jetzt
noch keine Argumente sondern erstmal nur
Pläne ich habe ein paar Punkte
vorgestellt der nächsten politischen
Handlungen die wir vornehmen das heißt
dass wir vor allem die
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit durch schnellere
Entscheidungen hochhalten wir werden die
Fachkräfte Frage lösen das heißt ein
Einwanderungsrecht schaffen und auch ein
Staatsbürgerschaft schaffen dass diese
Einwanderung für viele Menschen
attraktiv macht wenn man hier Leistung
bringt wenn man in Deutschland seine
Steuern zahlt dann soll man auch
perspektivisches Recht bekommen
Deutscher zu werden mit den Pflichten
gehen auch Rechte einher wir werden auf
den amerikanischen den Flächen reduction
Act ein großes Investitionsprogramm eine
adäquate europäische Antwort geben und
dann lang dieser Punkte haben wir
konkret diskutiert wie sie aussehen
können und ich glaube dass wir mit
Seminar Aufbruchstimmung aus diesem
Kongress rausgegangen sind trotzdem hört
man ja aus der Wirtschaft sehr viel
klagen sie haben den Klimaschutz an sich
gezogen sie wollten den Umbau der
Wirtschaft gestalten jetzt aber geht es
erstmal um Standortsicherung
Energiebeschaffung und das Hochfahren
von Kohlekraftwerken und die Wirtschaft
beklagt bemängelt dass sie zu sehr
gegängelt wird und zu wenig unterstützt
es ist die Kritik berechtigt das war
jedenfalls nicht heute der Sound des
Tages sondern ganz im Gegenteil die
Wirtschaft hat erkannt und will die
dekarbonisierung zu einem Geschäft und
Erfolgsmodell für den deutschen Standort
für die deutsche Industrie machen man
muss sich einmal anschauen was die
Amerikaner gerade tun sie haben ein
großes Investitionsprogramm aufgelegt
für erneuerbare Energien für E-Mobilität
für Batterien für Halbleitertechnik und
Elektrolyse und Wasserstoff damit ist
auch klar jedem müsste jetzt klar sein
dass der Wettbewerb um die zukünftigen
Märkte über die Klimaneutralität der
Produktionsweisen erfolgt das weiß die
Wirtschaft die muss ich nicht überzeugen
sie sind Partner und alliierte in dieser
in diesem Wettbewerb mit den anderen
globalen Mächten in Deutschland ist die
Situation in der politischen Klasse
mitunter etwas anders wir drohen ein
bisschen die
enge Grenze zwischen berechtigten klagen
und großen Nöten denn die in der Preise
sind ja hoch für sehr viele Unternehmen
hoch nicht einzuhalten die Grenze nicht
einzuhalten es gibt auf der anderen
Seite geradezu eine Lust am beschreiben
des Untergangs das nützt aber niemanden
etwas wir müssen damit eine Haltung
reingehen dass wir die Probleme lösen
die Herausforderung angehen und nicht
den Standort schlecht reden und das war
der Geist des heutigen Tages und das ist
meine Botschaft der glaubt dass wir die
Industrie in Deutschland fallen lassen
der hat die Rechnung ohne die Industrie
ohne die Innovationskraft der Industrie
aber mit Verlag auch ohne die
entschlossen mit der Bundesregierung
gemacht das wird nicht passieren die an
der Lust am Untergang beteiligt sich
auch die Opposition Friedrich Merz hat
gestern eine selbst für die Opposition
ungewöhnlich scharfe Attacke gegen sie
geritten und hat gesagt es viele an
Sachverstand bei Ihnen und auch im
ganzen Ministerium und es müsse einen
Neuanfang geben Fichte das eigentlich an
wenn die Opposition sowas sagt nein
okay was soll ich sagen Friedrich Merz
hat im Frühjahr gefordert dass wir ein
Gas im Bago einführen also nicht wie es
jetzt passiert ist im Sommer Putin uns
das Gas abstellt sondern Herr März
wollte und das muss man mal übersetzen
dass wir dafür beitragen dass die
gastspeicher nicht gefüllt sind werden
wir Herr märz und seinem großen
ökonomischen Sachverstand gefolgt wir
hatten heute eine eine nicht
beherrschbare Situation mit Verlaub das
fühlt mich nicht an
die Leute in Deutschland sind ja im
Grunde alle für Klimaschutz aber am
ehesten wenn Sie ihn nicht bezahlen
müssen wann sagt die Regierung wann
sagen sie uns eigentlich dass es den
Umbau der Wirtschaft nicht umsonst gibt
und unser Wohlstand vielleicht so nicht
zu halten sein wird das sind zwei Dinge
die man auseinanderhalten muss natürlich
müssen wir investieren und
selbstverständlich ist der Verlust von
billigen russischen Gas für die
Industrie und die Arbeitsplätze die
daran hängen eine Herausforderung sonst
hätten sie ja nicht das billige
russische Gas genommen wenn es nicht
billig gewesen wäre das ist ja so schwer
nicht zu verstehen also wird es teuer
werden wir tragen diese Last ja gerade
die hohe Inflation kommt genau daher es
fehlt günstige Energie sie muss jetzt
teurer besorgt werden also wir zahlen
einen Preis ohne Fragezeichen wie ein
Preis für das in der Mittelfrist
zwingend zu einem Wohlstandsverlust und
dann sage ich nein das tut es nicht es
gibt da keinen Naturgesetz das ist immer
so weitergehen muss die erneuerbaren
Energien sind jetzt schon in den
Produktionskosten
günstiger als neue fossile Energien sie
werden also wenn wir sie klug und
großflächig einsetzen zu einer sehr
wettbewerbsfähigen Wirtschaft und zu
einer günstigen Energieversorgung in
Deutschland führen sagt Robert Habeck
Wirtschafts- und klimaschutzminister aus
Berlin herzlichen Dank dahin ich danke
Ihnen
und das Gespräch haben wir vor einer
knappen Stunde aufgezeichnet
wir bleiben beim Thema Wirtschaft und
dabei was sie tun muss um der Zerstörung
unseres Planeten entgegen zu wirken bis
zu 9 Millionen Tier- und Pflanzenarten
soll es noch auf der Erde geben viele
davon noch unerforscht doch es werden
immer weniger mindestens eine von acht
Arten ist bereits in Gefahr so haben es
besonders die Amphibien schwer die
goldkröte aus Lateinamerika endgültig
ausgestorben oder die mindestantilope
schon nahezu verschwunden und auch
Süßwasser Tierarten sind extrem
gefährdet der chinesische flussdelphin
ein Wesen der Vergangenheit auch
beeindruckende Tiere wie das nördliche
Breitmaulnashorn könnten bald aussterben
von dieser Unterart gibt es nur noch
zwei lebende Exemplare die großen
UN-Konferenzen zur Biodiversität der
letzten 30 Jahre haben daran nicht viel
geändert anfang dezember startet die
nächste
Material
während die Klimakonferenzen eine
riesige Aufmerksamkeit bekommen fristet
das Artensterben eher ein Schattendasein
Christine Elsner berichtet
die tropischen Anden in Südamerika sie
zählen zu den artenreichsten Regionen
der Erde
doch die einzigartige Tier- und
Pflanzenwelt sie ist in Gefahr
Kettensägen Bagger und Brandrodung
fressen sich immer tiefer in den Urwald
so entstehen Flächen für den Sojaanbau
und die kinderzucht die Produkte
gelangen auf den Weltmarkt in der
Erdgeschichte gab es zwar immer schon
mal ein massenhaftes Artensterben etwa
bei der letzten Eiszeit jetzt aber
schlagen Wissenschaftler Alarm
leider befinden wir uns in einer
dramatischen Krise der Biodiversität wir
sind im sechsten Massensterben eine
Millionen Tier- und Pflanzenarten sind
vom Aussterben bedroht geschätzt
verlieren wir 150 Arten pro Tag also ist
eine ganz dramatische Situation und
damit zerstören wir das Netz des Lebens
Biodiversität ist ein Wirtschaftsfaktor
sie liefert uns Rohstoffe wie etwa Holz
Insekten bestäuben unsere Nutzpflanzen
fruchtbare Böden liefern unser täglich
Brot und viele Medikamente enthalten
pflanzliche Wirkstoffe
in Summe hat das einen wirtschaftlichen
Nutzen von ungefähr 170 bis 190
Billionen US-Dollar pro Jahr
der Wert geht aber jährlich um
mindestens 6 Billionen US-Dollar zurück
wichtigste Treiber des
bio-diversitätsverlustes sind Fischerei
und Aquakulturen Waldwirtschaft
Textilindustrie chemischer Industrie und
Bergbau wird die Natur weiterhin
geplündert fehlt unserer Erde ein
wichtiger Dienstleister die
sauerstofflieferung wird eingeschränkt
der Wasserkreislauf wird instabil die
kühlende Wirkung aufs Erdklima versagt
der anhaltende Zerstörungsprozess er hat
ungeahnte Folgen
besonders im Amazonasgebiet nähern wir
uns einem dramatischen Kipppunkt ab 20
Prozent Entwaldung stirbt nämlich der
Wald selber weil dann nicht mehr
ausreichend verdunstungs Niederschlag
zur Verfügung steht das
wasseroberflächlich abläuft
alarmierend schon jetzt liegt die
Entwaldung im Amazonasgebiet bei 18
Prozent
so verwandelt sich eine artenreiche
Schatzkammer langsam in eine Steppe die
Natur muss mehr Ruhe finden um sich zu
regenerieren daher die klare Forderung
also die vielleicht wichtigste Konferenz
in Montreal muss sehr sehr ambitionierte
Ziele verfolgen wir müssen Biodiversität
als die Grundlage allen unseres Handels
machen wir müssen die Schutzgebiete auf
30% an Land und dann mehr erhören wir
müssen runterkommen von dem Pestiziden
und der plastikverschmutzung
große Aufgaben warten auf die
Delegierten bei der
biodiversitätskonferenz doch es geht um
nichts Geringeres als um die Zukunft
unseres Planeten
und wir machen weiter mit den
Nachrichten und mit Gundula das 49
euro-ticket im nah und Regionalverkehr
soll nun spätestens zum ersten April
eingeführt werden
Bundesverkehrsminister Wissing hatte
ursprünglich einen Starttermin für
Anfang kommenden Jahres geplant strittig
bei den digitalen Beratungen der
Verkehrsminister von Bund und Ländern
bleibt weiterhin die Verteilung
möglicher Mehrkosten der Verband
Deutscher Verkehrsunternehmen warnte vor
einem finanziellen Risiko Thema der
Minister war auch die maskenpflicht im
öffentlichen Nahverkehr einen Endtermin
nannten sie heute aber noch nicht
Bundeskanzler Scholz hat sich auf dem
Gewerkschaftstag des deutschen
Beamtenbundes für eine faire und
wettbewerbsfähige Bezahlung im
öffentlichen Dienst ausgesprochen das
sei ein wichtiger Faktor um die
absehbare Lücke bei Fachkräften zu
schließen
die Einwanderung qualifizierte
Arbeitskräfte will die Bundesregierung
mit einem neuen Gesetz deutlich
erleichtern Fachkräfte aus nicht
EU-Staaten sollen zuwandern können auch
wenn sie keinen Arbeitsvertrag vorweisen
können ein Punktesystem sieht Kriterien
wie Qualifikation
Sprachkenntnisse
Berufserfahrung Deutschland Bezug und
Alter vor auf diesen Eckpunkten
basierend soll im Frühjahr ein Gesetz
erarbeitet werden
in China hat die Führung mit massiver
Polizeipräsenz in mehreren Städten
weitere Proteste gegen die harte
nullkovic-politik verhindert nach neuen
Aufrufen zu Demonstrationen wurde ein
Großaufgebot an Sicherheitskräften
mobilisiert trotz des Unmuts der
Bevölkerung hält die chinesische
Regierung an Ausgangssperren
zwangsquarantäne und Massentests fest
zudem kündigte die nationale
Gesundheitsbehörde eine Impfkampagne an
vor allem ältere Menschen sollen geimpft
werden
die inhaftierte belarussische
Oppositionelle Maria kolesnikowa liegt
auf der Intensivstation nach Angaben
ihrer Unterstützer ist sie bereits
gestern in ein Krankenhaus gebracht
worden die Ursache unbekannt die
40-Jährige war im vergangenen September
zu elf Jahren Haft verurteilt worden
wegen angeblicher Verschwörung zur Macht
Ergreifung sie ist eines der
bekanntesten Gesichter der landesweiten
Proteste in Belarus im Jahr 2020 gegen
lange Zeit Machthaber Lukaschenko
der ukrainische Außenminister
dimitriculierbar war wie immer knapp und
direkt schneller schneller schneller
brauche die Ukraine die Hilfe der 30
Nato-Partner
Luftabwehrraketen und Generatoren stehen
ganz oben auf seiner Bestellliste in
diesem Krieg in dem die russische Armee
brutal die Stromversorgung des Nachbarn
angreift die NATO sagte Unterstützung zu
und zwar so lange wie nötig das
Versprechen allerdings die Ukraine in
die westliche Militärallianz aufzunehmen
dass das Bündnis 2008 ebenfalls in
Bukarest gegeben hatte bleibt weiter
unerfüllt Florian neuhan berichtet aus
Rumänien
wenn die NATO ihre Fahnen im rumänischen
Bukarest auspackt dann ist das wie ein
Rendezvous mit der Geschichte mit der
des Ostblocks dem pompösen
Parlamentspalast einst er baut für
Diktator georgescu und mit der eigenen
Vergangenheit
2008 hatte die NATO in genau diesen
Palast über eine Zukunft Ukraine in der
NATO gestritten und das Land vor allem
auf Druck Deutschlands vertröstet ein
NATO Beitritt irgendwann aber nicht
jetzt
14 Jahre später
nato-treffen im selben Palast und die
Frage ob die Ukraine irgendwann Mitglied
wird ist wieder da vor allem auf Druck
der Osteuropäer
ich hoffe dass sie irgendeinen neuen
Ansatz finden für die künftige
NATO-Mitgliedschaft der Ukraine die ich
absolut unterstütze
lassen Sie mich betonen die
Voraussetzungen für eine neue
europäische Sicherheitsarchitektur ist
dass die Ukraine Teil der nato-familie
wird
es ist eine Debatte die sie hier
eigentlich nicht führen wollten es gibt
schließlich ganz akute sorgen etwa das
Millionen in der Ukraine wie diese
Familie in Kiew ohne Strom ohne Wasser
leben in Angst vor dem Winter nachdem
Russland gezielt die
Energieinfrastruktur angegriffen hatte
die deutsche Außenministerin reagiert
darauf mit einem Ausdruck der sonst nur
der eigenen deutschen Geschichte gilt
dem Holocaust
sondern mit unserer Zivilisation weil
wenn gezielt Infrastruktur bombardiert
wird dann nimmt man mutwillig in Kauf
Das Kinder das alte das Familien
erfrieren es ist was auch die
metropuliba fürchtet der ukrainische
Außenminister hat am Nachmittag in
Bukarest eine Wunschliste dabei
wir brauchen Flugabwehrsysteme wie zum
Beispiel Patrick Raketen und wir
brauchen Transformatoren die NATO
verspricht zu helfen bei der
Winterausrüstung der Armee beim
Wiederaufbau der Energieinfrastruktur
möglicherweise auch mit weiteren
Flugabwehrraketen klare zusagen aber
gibt es dazu heute nicht und der NATO
Beitritt der Ukraine irgendwann
vielleicht aber nicht jetzt
diskutieren wie wir unsere Partnerschaft
mit der Ukraine weiter stärken und uns
in Richtung einer Mitgliedschaft bewegen
die NATO Alliierten haben hier die
Entscheidung von Bukarest 2018
bekräftigt
es bleibt ein Versprechen ohne Datum ein
Land im Krieg könnte die NATO ohnehin
nicht aufnehmen wer weiß ob man beim
nächsten Gipfel in diesem Palast soweit
ist
und wir machen noch mal weiter mit
Nachrichten aus der Wirtschaft und
Gundula überraschend heute die Meldung
vom Statistischen Bundesamt die
Inflation in Deutschland hat im November
nachgelassen auf glatt zehn Prozent im
Oktober lag sie noch bei 10,4 Prozent
Sina meinitz wie bewerten die Experten
an der Börse diesen leichten Rückgang ja
die Experten sehen ist hier tatsächlich
recht nüchtern ein Volkswirt sagte wir
nähern uns dem Gipfel aber für einen
Sturm der Begeisterung ist es definitiv
noch zu früh auch der Aktienmarkt blieb
von der Nachricht weitestgehend
unbeeindruckt moderate Verluste beim DAX
und am Ende ein Stand von
14.355 Punkten dieser leichte Rückgang
der Inflation im November kam zwar
überraschend Entwarnung gibt es aber
eben noch nicht verantwortlich für
diesen moderaten Preisanstieg sind die
leicht gesunkenen Energiepreise in
diesem Monat im Geldbeutel bleibt der
noch nichts mehr übrig denn die Gehälter
werden von der Inflation schlichtweg
aufgefressen die Einkommen sind nominal
um 2,3 gewachsen die reale lohnverlust
beträgt 5,7 Prozent und ist damit der
stärkste seit dem Jahr 2008 bereits das
vierte Mal in Folge müssen
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer nun
ein real- und Verlust aufgrund von
steigenden Preisen hinnehmen dieser
hauchdünne Rückgang der Inflation in
Deutschland von 10,4 Prozent auf 10%,
der stimmt zwar hoffnungsvoll für den
weiteren Kurs der Europäischen
Zentralbank entscheidend sind nun die
für morgen angekündigten Inflationsraten
der Eurozone erklärtes Ziel der EZB ist
es ja dass die Teuerung zurückgeht
deshalb hat sie dieses Jahr auch schon
dreimal den Leitzins erhöht die Zahlen
morgen könnten dann Rückschlüsse auf die
weitere Zinspolitik der Notenbank geben
vielen Dank Sina nach Frankfurt
der größte aktive Vulkan der Welt der
Mauna Loa auf Hawaii spuckt seit gestern
wieder Lava bislang betroffen ist nur
der Gipfelbereich Ortschaften am Fuß des
Vulkans dagegen nicht der maronaloa ist
knapp 4.200 Meter hoch zuletzt
ausgebrochen war er im April 1984 die
Behörden haben wegen der Asche Wolken
und Gase eine Gesundheitswarnung
herausgegeben eine Attraktion für
Touristen ist der Vulkanausbruch aber
schon
zum ersten Mal in der Geschichte der
Fußball-WM der Männer wird eine
Schiedsrichterin ein Spiel leiten die
Französin Stefanie frappar am Donnerstag
das dritte Deutsche Gruppenspiel gegen
Costa Rica und hier sind noch die
Ergebnisse der WM Spiele von heute
gerade eben gegen die Partie zwischen
Wales und England zu Ende gewonnen hat
England mit drei zu null und steht damit
im Achtelfinale zu dem anderen Spiel in
der Gruppe B gleich mehr zuvor hatten in
der Gruppe A die Niederlande den schon
ausgeschiedenen Gastgeber Katar 2:0
besiegt und Ecuador gegen Afrika Meister
Senegal eins zu zwei verloren damit
haben sich die Niederlande und Senegal
für das Achtelfinale qualifiziert
viele Iraner sind fußballbegeistert und
Zweifeln trotzdem ob sie die eigene
Mannschaft diesmal unterstützen sollen
es ist nämlich unklar für welchen Iran
die Spieler eigentlich stehen für das
Regime oder für die Menschen die seit
Monaten gegen die Mullahs auf die Straße
gehen die Mannschaft hatte das Singen
der iranischen Hymne einmal verweigert
beim zweiten Spiel vermutlich unter
erheblichen Druck aber mitgemacht
iranische Fans die nach Doha gereist
sind und die Proteste unterstützen
fühlen sich beobachtet und verfolgt
angeblich hat die iranische Regierung
nicht nur bestellte Jubler nach Katar
geschickt sondern auch als Zuschauer
verkleidete Sicherheitsbeamte obendrein
heißt der Gegner heute auch noch USA der
Erzfeind des Regimes
über politisierte und verunsicherte Fans
ein historisches Spiel schon lange
ausverkauft für das regime-interan ist
der Match gegen den Erzfeind USA vor
allem eine große propaganda-show nicht
einmal in dual ersten regime-vertreter
regierungskritische Iraner aussprechen
sie schikanieren alle sie drangsalieren
alle um sie herum genau das und die
Katara lassen es zu
als er über die Revolution der Frauen im
Iran reden will wird er unterbrochen von
regimekräften Milizen und Angehörige die
zahlreich nach Katar entsandt worden
sind
während sie sich also frei bewegen und
alles überwachen können werden andere
iranische Fans allein für das Tragen
eines T-Shirts auf dem Frau Leben
Freiheit steht von katarischen
Sicherheitskräften bedrängt oder
festgenommen
auch sie joshita wurde während eines
Interviews von regime-anhängern getreten
ihre Plakate für Irans Frauen zerrissen
für die Katara war sie die schuldige sie
wurde bis auf die Unterwäsche ausgezogen
und verhört
ich weiß wirklich nicht wie ich mich
heute fühlen soll weder will ich dass
sie verlieren noch dass sie gewinnen
unsere Priorität ist jetzt nicht der
Fußball ich bin hier um die Stimme
meines Volkes zu sein
[Musik]
die Pressekonferenz der us-mannschaft
gestern geprägt von Angriffen iranischer
Staatsmedien denn der us-fußballverband
hatte zeitweilig Irans Flagge ohne das
Emblem des Regimes gepostet als Zeichen
des Respekts vor Irans Demonstrierenden
Frauen die Spieler und die Belegschaft
wussten darüber wirklich nichts wir
können uns nur als Mannschaft dafür
entschuldigen
die US-Fans geben sich im Stadion betont
unpolitisch alles sei wunderbar einfach
ein klasse Abend
wir sind so aufgeregt das ist eine tolle
Möglichkeit für die USA ein guter Test
für die Mannschaft es ist eine Ehre hier
zu sein
der US-Sender ist hier in N berichtet
auf Irans Spieler sei Druck ausgeübt
worden des Regime bedrohe ihre Familie
als die Hymne ertönt und die Spieler
Mitsingen anders als beim Spiel gegen
England hat joshita Tränen in den Augen
demonstrativ gut sie die Machthaber des
Iran aus jene die ihr die Freude an
diesem Spiel genommen haben
und das Spiel Iran gegen USA ist gerade
zu Ende gegangen mit 0:1 die Iraner sind
damit ausgeschieden das war es von uns
für heute bleibt noch der Hinweis auf
die nachfolgende Reportage aus der Reihe
37 Grad die wirklich ans Herz geht sie
erzählt von einem Chor mit krebskranken
Menschen der voller Lebensfreude gegen
die Hoffnungslosigkeit an singt
0.30 ist hier dann wieder Zeit für unser
heute journal Update mit Nazan gökte mir
die heute mit diw-chef Fratzscher
spricht morgen melden wir uns dann in
der Halbzeitpause wir wünschen Ihnen
einen schönen Abend und tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter über Russland hat
sich dieses sehr umfangreiche
hochgebildet und das lenkte auf seiner
Südseite kalte Luft in unsere Richtung
erreicht uns aber noch nicht die Tiefs
haben keine Chance dagegen müssen in den
Süden ausweichen zum Beispiel hier
Richtung Mittelmeer und sorgen dort für
heftige Unwetter oder aber auf dem
Atlantik sie müssen weiter Richtung
Norden und nehmen dazu sehr feuchte und
warme Luft mit bis in die Arktis hinein
ja und in der Nacht gibt es im Westen
Deutschlands kompakte Wolken hier fällt
etwas Regen raus genauso wie im
Südwesten sonst aber es ist trocken und
es bildet sich teilweise Nebel Richtung
Bayern und das bei tiefsten Temperaturen
von -1° dort und sechs Grad z.B am
Niederrhein ja und morgen weiterhin
kompakte Wolken hauptsächlich westlich
des Rheins und hier fällt etwas Regen
raus es wird tatsächlich sprührigen sein
sonst im Osten zeigt sich auch mal die
Sonne die Temperaturen dazu höchste
Werte mit einem Grad im Vogtland und 9
Grad im Rhein-Main-Gebiet das ist die
Temperatur Spanne die nächsten Tage am
Donnerstag ist es trocken teilweise auch
mit sonnigen Abschnitten im Süden bei 0
bis 7 Grad am Freitag wird es etwas
kälter und von Osten her kommt durchaus
etwas Schnee auf ähnlich sieht es dann
am Samstag aus bei minus ein bis sechs
Grad und etwas Schneefall damit wünsche
ich Ihnen einen schönen Abend